[Applause]
all right
so this is this is about to be available
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's the matter
um
it was wet oh
were you not given the audio guide no no
no no I I got here late here
thank you
hi I'm Jacob Ticketmaster let me be the
first to thank you for sitting in the
least desirable seats of the whole
theater the back corner because of what
the Swiss call the tiatar Bobbers what
the Germans call schwein on penis and
what we in America call Ticketmaster
babies my family proudly genetically
engineered these night freaks in the
1920s in a quest to create an usher that
could live within the theater walls and
subsist solely off of wood and Twizzler
pull and peels Jesus unfortunately
went so so wrong and now we are stuck
with these unspeakable Horrors who pop
out of the theater walls and try to give
you a kiss
what the kiss of the pig is what the
Germans call it eyeless and the
teata barber is a nightmare to behold
Judy Garland has a wonderful quote about
them to call them a beaver is an insult
to Beavers genetically they're actually
closer to a spider or a mosquito
yeah Judy Garland under knack for
zoology I'm holding one now that as you
can see is in shock from a Twizzler
binge this is a ghastly sight to come
popping out in the middle of a
theatrical performance so we're going to
need you to confirm your willingness to
perform the role of Father inspector to
an usher vocally the Usher will then
give you a spray to defend yourself
should
come popping out looking for a smooch
they won't rest till they get their
kisses so it is up to you to protect
yourself from the penisless pigs thank
you for coming tonight and please enjoy
tonight's performance of Stomp Avenue Q
or Chris Fleming may I have a verbal
confirmation of your consent to be a
barber inspector tonight yeah you know
it's it's it's
kind of a tall order but okay
use as much as you want
but want as much as you use
[Music]
my queen I have failed you
how many patrons did you Jesus
barely silence oh
yeah what are you doing get to First
with at least five patrons why nice fall
then you will be banished to a dinner
theater in Phoenix where they do murder
mystery comedies please my queen I'll
give you my family's rations for this
whole week
Squad peasant I could floss with those
bone
like a dock of boat with my poop
now go plant one on five patrons before
the night is up or you will be flying
Spirit to Maricopa County tonight
hi Daddy how's work will you be home
early tonight no girls not tonight
Daddy's got some smooching to do
[Music]